[Musique]
qu'ils soient pour la grande route pour
la ville pour le sentier où qu'ils
soient électriques
ce printemps la mode et aux vélos encore
plus que l'an dernier
au niveau du 60 à 90% des vélos qui
était commandée dans toutes les
catégories
lemay des catégories ou est-ce que la
difficulté à trouver de nouveaux stocks
comme un exemple on a réussi à 20 je
pense je demanderai du procès et ont
duré la femme étaient partis comme même
le mois de mars là on a même triplé les
chefs le c'est incroyable parce que les
voyages sont incertains les salles de
gym fermer le transport en commun moins
attirant les québécois décide de rouler
on a fait notre record de vélo au québec
l'année pass cyclistes aguerris
mario et micheline avaient déjà leur
vélo mais ils ont voulu acheter des
pièces impossible on voulait faire
transformer pour mettre un guide
endroits qui sont des vélos de route et
on a essayé de voir des modifications
ils ont pas les matériels sont même pas
capables d'avoir les pièces marc burg
bridge lui venait payer un acompte sur
le vélo qu'il a acheté cet hiver enfin
l'été dernier j'ai vendu mon vélo parce
que c'était la folie tout le monde a
cherché un dont c'était le bon moment
devant mon vieux vélos pensant que je
vais m'en procurer rapidement au début
du printemps est malheureusement bien
que je les réserve il ya deux mois
c'est ces soldats partout son vendeur
peine à recevoir les commandes de ces
fabricants qu'est-ce qu'on soit sept ans
et on les attendait au mois d'août mais
après vingt années passées à fixer les
marchands pour finir le vélo c'est ainsi
aucune pièce pour nous livrer un exemple
le fabricant des vélos opus basé à
montréal les opus sont fabriqués en
partie dans l'arrondissement
saint-laurent en partie en asie
ici on parle des dérailleurs deschamps
une épidémie les cadres tout ça il ya
tellement de demandes que les fabricants
en orient ont partout à travers le monde
sont pas capables de suffire à la
demande
alors limiter les des fabrications
s'allonger sa longue
à l'heure actuelle des milliers de
personnes attendent leur vélo opus
ils devront être patients on va livrer
jusqu'au mois de novembre et décembre
meine zeit
2021 pour des vélos qui nous ont été
commandés au mois de septembre l'année
dernière devant la difficulté d'acheter
du neuf
plusieurs cyclistes se tourner vers les
vélos d'occasion les annonces se
multiplient sur internet et le marché
favorise les vendeurs tiens qui menait
au magasin pour nous raconter seraient
achetés sont venus en 2015 puis lâche tu
penses qu'un simple jeu vendu 17,1 au
magasin le prix des vélos neufs a aussi
augmenté par rapport à l'année dernière
souvent de 10% et plus et la pénurie
pourrait se poursuivre encore longtemps
en raison de la demande mondiale ou 2022
voire assez critique aussi la au constat
que dans le vélo de montagne et dans
l'électrique ça va continuer au delà des
deux prochaines années la demande un
avantage de la pandémie
les québécois auront découvert ou
redécouvert le vélo et c'est bien fait
ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada
m'ont rien
[Musique]